I know you shed tears
I know you continued to shed tears every
day because of man's ingratitude
you choose Souls
and despite my unworthiness you've
chosen me
the primary source of all human
oppression and exploitation is
individual property what is he talking
about he's talking about
how we can get control of Our Lives
[Music]
I know you'll give me what I need I know
you will not refuse let me courage I
know you will provide
or is a terrible thing do not let Satan
take advantage of your suffering
[Music]
it feels like I send a question these
things it feels like a center
the Lord
there is no greater love than this to
keep one's life for one's friends
knowing about it
say Christ is Lord say Christ is Lord
get out fill out
prepare the fire
thank you